we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a doozy of a
voicemail from this anti-vaccine woman
who keeps calling in
this may actually be the nuttiest
anti-vax call we've ever had take a
listen to this
okay
forgot a word I remember
why remember I never claim to be a
doctor nor to be formulating the things
I say about the vaccine on my own I'm
merely reporting on that which we get
from
epidemiologists immunologists public
health researchers Etc
why do uh
intra muscular
injections require
um
God aspiration
go ahead and look it up okay look it up
in any of your [ __ ] medical journals
Mr genius Pacman my journals
this Dr John Campbell
a doctorate in nursing
[Music]
yeah by the way I mean without even
giving my opinion on John Campbell I've
seen some of his videos he has an
interesting YouTube channel some of his
videos are are interesting to me some
are less interesting
um he he has a PHD in health science and
like the teaching of of Health Science
um and a doctorate in philosophy so I
mean it just we should just mention he's
not a medical doctor that that's not
praise or an attack but even just you
know the again Dr Jill Biden shouldn't
be called doctor you be the judge you be
the judge as to when we should use the
term doctor when we're talking about
someone who's talking about medicine I
don't know no he's not
there are numerous studies out there
like like you're saying there aren't any
there's like one study out of wherever
you're so [ __ ] foolish
it's listed as a one of the most
essential drugs in the World Health
Organization yeah I think she's talking
about Ivermectin and of course that
doesn't mean it's works for covid
you know why would they give a dog the
same penicillin that they give a human
why
you know what you know what this is all
about this is all about selling
vaccinations to people and making
billions we not only paid for the
vaccines to be developed now we got to
pay the mother
like big bucks
right so
um I I don't think there's any bringing
her back
I I just don't think there's any
bringing her back if you think there
might be please explain to me how on
today's bonus show producer Pat makes
his triumphant return
we will hear what he's been up to we
will talk about the resignation of NFL
coach John Gruden after uh homophobic
racist and misogynistic emails we will
talk about how the New York City Schools
vaccine mandate is going and we will
talk about the approval by the FDA of
another rapid antigen test what's
different about this rapid test for
covid we will discuss in detail all of
those stories on today's bonus show sign
up at joinpakman.com you can use the
coupon code better21 to save if you want
you don't have to you decide and we will
speak to you on the bonus show in mere
moments